yeah bro i went to the i was telling
chappelle it's in the car bro
now correct me if i'm tripping right so
after the workout worked out heavy with
my boy kevin bay i was like man i need a
massage he was like go to sunrise
massage park
um that's what chapter already the name
straight
okay i didn't know sunrise yeah so i get
there
i see a subway i see a 7-eleven
are we deshawn watson you're getting
tracked off doug
i thought i was but i didn't listen and
again i get there the guy is laying down
like this
and he's like oh you could you know it's
during the day he's oh all right he was
laying down waiting for him
down like that asian guy right so he's a
gold background cool whatever he's like
what are you getting i was like a full
body
asked if you've been here before no you
didn't okay okay so she's
a red flag but he probably he probably
knew you ain't never been in there
before
yeah not a lot of black people no that's
that's a code word though oh it is
you've been here before
because you know oh
okay so he comes back he was like yeah
we got a masseuse ready for you so i'm
getting a girl or something like that
guy shows up ooh so i was like okay cool
again dishonored
that's cool though
no i can't relax it's just too it's too
erotic it's too like sensitive you rub
it on me
yeah you're rubbing them yeah and i i
really gotta get in that ass
like to ask they're getting their ass
that's cheeks i didn't ask for that i
totally stay away from the ass cheeks
yeah okay
cool so uh because again uh a small
asian man small
you might as well asian girl the same
strength usually it was the same history
when
that guy was massaging me so goddamn
hard at the store really
bro bro i'm not lying to you
like i was like we got in there you got
in there oh you got the real deal holy
feel
listen this guy was how much was it it
was 58 god this has happy ending written
all over it again
do me a favor google it do this go to
rub maps dot com are you waitmaps.com
and type in the name of this place okay
we'll find out if you went to happy
ending place
okay what is what is this suspended oh
how
dare they oh what is this dishon watch
this stuff uh
there's also that shooting in atlanta oh
yeah okay rub maps
rub maps dot ch no yeah that's it
i'm already telling you oh yes this is
how you find out if
you're going to a happy ending type in
sunrise
uh massage uh at uh sunrise
sunrise and there's gonna be a million
sunrise but let's see what happens
in uh sunrise florida
let's see it's probably not a happy
ending place yeah it's probably why i
guarantee it it is they ain't gonna
promote that european sun
sunshine oh sunshine there there's some
chinese
[ __ ] yeah right there that's it oh no
it is
it is dog there you go oh it's a rubbing
tuck yeah how do you know
we're just saying because it's on his
way masseuse ethnicity chinese
there's two reviews scroll down chrissy
ask for chrissy ask for cucco
and if you want to see the premium
they'll tell you how you get it done yep
there you go okay solved
i could add chrissy i could have chrissy
and i got chip i'm sorry
or chrissy but you went with greg
and he was digging like he was hurting
me and then i was like
i'm trying to take you know he's only in
there like if if he thinks he doesn't
trust your where he's like [ __ ] i guess
i'll do this bro
hold on i'm glad it's more to the story
so he's misogyny i had to literally stop
him like hold on bro my ally
stop like you stop hurting me yeah right
as i look up
you know you know it's curtains yep i
see so when they they said like yo
change your clothes they get you give
you these shorts wait did you have a
room to yourself
no you had a room but there was curtains
yeah there's curtains was there red
lights
it was red lights what are we doing dude
why wouldn't you get jacked off this is
a signature
signature venue for happy ending
red lights no like curtains
the [ __ ] dudes sleeping as you enter
the room
he's like oh [ __ ] you here for cougar
nah man i'm here for greg i'll get
regret
i just want the regular [ __ ] all right
that's all you had to do
i gotta do actual word i think it was
him at the front
he's like i think i remember how to do
this
he said hey man you cool with 30. i
can't do the hour though
an hour ain't it i don't have an hour
ending man you're cool i haven't done
this in a while you cool with 30.
are you cool with a hot 15. you cool
with an aggressive 15.
i swear i'll get everything done dude
i'll get just i just need
i'm exhausted i've been here all day
usually for this no i that place is
signature happy ending i didn't know bro
they had the respect to a
subway somebody you could have got an
interception
you got a six inch this this should have
been your day okay this story should go
like this okay
yeah man i went to sunrise massage
parlor got
jacked off by cucco and then got a
six-inch
[ __ ] meatball sub what a day what a
nice day
that wasn't i like that he went
meatballs yeah that's a good one okay we
don't [ __ ] with the tuna because you
know it's not real thank you
[ __ ] tuna if i do it also i'll do the
six inch i'll do the footlong
oh with a full [ __ ] well i cannot yeah i
could not finish the food
they put that parmesan cheese on top and
we know that's not real meat bro
you know what they do sometimes too
throw no pepperonis on there
yeah and they put the cheese on top
dog you could have got that ass played
with and haven't had that
long sub what is this the greatest
saturday of all time
how was the weather popping it was great
oh dude and then you hit some fastballs
with these pro
mlb players what a great saturday
afternoon
but instead you had greg rub your heart
i didn't know and demon get a [ __ ]
foot long and then didn't they almost
rob you oh yeah that's what i'm saying
so look dude this place is so
cliche happy ending bro so when i'm
facing that
always you know so you know when you go
face down they have the hole in the face
yeah
yeah so you're like this and can barely
breathe yeah and then if it's a real
massage you're no search running yeah so
it's a happy ending you're just
you're rock hard with your boner so you
take your shoes and you put the money
in your shoes so you have eyes on the
shoes oh
your name that's who tried to rob me so
i look up she's hot
no so she goes nah she wasn't how cause
she had a mask on i didn't see too much
but again he's rubbing me i look up and
i have all my wallet my phone everything
in that bin because i have different
pair of shorts on
and she's going through it i'm like what
you doing and she was like no i'm moving
the fan i'm moving
the fan haven't been on the whole time
and i was like hold on
are you trying to rob me and it was like
the guy's like not not not no she'd get
the fan
i was alright they're looking for that
cash daddy
they're trying to get that mood because
they clearly they they he's not here for
a dog
did they have the sprayer with the oil
in it yeah yep this is signature [ __ ]
happy ending
shout out to sunrise
you can add such a nice experience man
all right handy at the front
the bowl of candy yeah they always yeah
yeah this is great man every massage
fall i had
i cannot i could not get a [ __ ]
massage to save my life oh i love them
i love them too
i don't know about sunrise massage like
an actual massage i [ __ ] with
you you never like so you never say get
a dude
never no i can't i can't relax with a
guy i know it's probably a better
massage because you know they're strong
but dude you get some of them
those little thai girls walking on your
back oh they're walking they walk
oh yeah they have bars in the [ __ ]
stomp on your back
yeah eat that like a hate stomp like
[ __ ]
hate stuff oh it's nice crack all those
the [ __ ] [ __ ] can you get massages
one one time i did like a couple weeks
but i went to like a
little franchise one you went to massage
nba
yeah you gotta like wear [ __ ] full
clothes like what are we doing
wait when they wait when they tell you
to change your clothes
you're not supposed to so when they come
back so wait when you you were naked
that's what i think they try to see if
you're a cop or not right so if
i didn't change it
if you're if you're looking for that
type of action
you should be butt naked face up when
they walk in the room that's what they
say because cops aren't going to do that
and then they always ask have you been
here before and it's always cash
there's cash right yeah yeah yes i mean
i mean they have reviews on rub mat
not from greg it was just it was just
not from yeah greg's name
ryan's not on
hey i didn't know bro i really wanted a
massage and was it kind of outside
things like was it out like it wasn't
like
next to like the shopping center like
the mall
yeah what was it next i told you a
subway a 7-eleven yeah yeah yeah
across the street was a gas station yep
yeah so that was all signs
that's all okay rub and tuck i didn't
know look at chin searching
okay you get massages no i don't you
don't like it either
um i just never really went out of my
way for one i feel like i need it though
would you do you do it yeah if it's a
real massage well people don't like that
doesn't like them my brothers
no they won't do it so like that's true
jay doesn't even like hugs
if it's a real massage i can get my
wrists my feet
yeah my glutes some people hate massages
like jay doesn't like to be touched
yeah you need to do i don't like yeah
he's on you when people come up and like
touch my shoulders and [ __ ] i'm like
yeah jay also hates that yeah i don't
like it he would never do a massage i
love massage me too
if they're good there's nothing better
yeah bro it's the best thing at all but
again i would never do it with a guy i
felt uncomfortable i didn't know you can
ask for a woman
you know i just thought they'd sign you
a masseuse yeah
no they knew you weren't there for the
yeah i told them i told them i was like
there was an app i used where they come
to the house
i forget what they're doing oh they come
to the house yeah it's like running or
something like that i had that on my
birthday it's great
and they bring all everything they bring
the kid they get it yeah they bring
everything they don't really do that
yeah does it does
doesn't get in the massage like make you
kind of like nauseous uh it can make you
sick because releases a bunch of toxins
so if you're like starting to get sick
it'll really make you sicker oh really
like your nose are running [ __ ]
i'll tell you what if i'm running down i
don't want to massage because it makes
me sicker if you if you're what
if i'm like run down like i want to get
one now so you have to be like
remember lex set me up with massage
miami but i was like i'm good man
because i could tell i wasn't getting
good sleep
yeah yeah off stage in the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song